ils sont 20 pour un seul titre et une
concurrence parfaitement équilibré cette
martinique et 7 guadeloupéens et 6
revenons de l'hexagone avantage du
terrain ou pas ce sont quand même les
régionaux qui ont pris l'avantagé sur
cette édition 2010 9 et même plus
particulièrement évoque les noirs à
l'image de sébastien buts et il a
remporté toutes les manches sur les
quatre jours de course
à l'exception d'une disqualification sur
la 5eme sans incidence puisque chaque
concurrent retire du classement son plus
mauvais résultat
sa victoire 2019 lui offre désormais des
nouvelles ambitions
c'est quelque chose d'important ça me
permet de me sélectionner pour les
championnats de france en août à brest
et oui c'est toujours ça fait toujours
du bien de dominer sur sur un plan d'eau
comme ce cher qui est très difficile et
sur une semaine nautique de renommée à
noter que la famille buquet réalisé un
coup double puisque dans l'autre série
plus toilé mais avec moins de
concurrence son grand frère guillaume
s'impose après un duel très serré avec
kilian l'hosto mais revenons dans la
série précédente pour la deuxième place
après les premiers jours indécis c'est
finalement le guadeloupéen matteo
bourgeois qui s'y installent lui aussi
régulier est habitué aux vents forts
il a su maîtriser ces dernières manches
et surveiller ses adversaires le premier
il était à 6 points d'avance je me suis
dit normalement si compliqué que je
passe premier à moins que il ya un petit
miracle et le troisième du coup il faut
juste que je fasse assez attention et
puis normalement ça le fait sur le plan
d'eau vous surveiller à oui on se
regarde à chaque fois on sait toujours
où l autre et on se relâche pas dans
l'oeil l'autre c'est noah guiraud il
complète le podium de la série à 14 ans
pour sa troisième semaine nautique mais
sa première sur ce type de planche à
voile
il y fait une belle entrée même si
lançant une pointe de déception
savoir enfin heureux je suis content
n'hésitez plus enfin jouer et j'aurais
préféré être deux mais bon voilà experts
donc pas trop tête de la glisse un peu
je pense je suis pas très bon dans le
vent général donc bon après dix à onze
manches disputées en fonction des séries
c'est la clôture de la semaine l'outil
une semaine de chercheurs une nouvelle
fois bénis par des conditions de
navigation idéales